check the mic and make sure it sound
right boy
it's been 20 long years since claude a
mute criminal was double-crossed by his
girlfriend and sent to prison in the
original gta 3. that game changed how
open world video games were made and the
subsequent games in the series vice city
and san andreas became two of the most
loved games in history and now all three
games are back for some well-needed
nostalgia and for a whole new generation
of gamers to understand what all the
fuss was about back then i'm gonna break
this video into two sections first all
the updates that have come to the games
after all these years then we'll break
down what each game does differently and
hopefully you can do me a favor and let
me know which game you'd like videos
based around first i'm adam and this is
20 things you need to know about the gta
trilogy definitive edition
let's start with a quick note the
definitive edition of gta has two
release dates for everyone who likes
digital games november the 11th is the
day we can start playing but if you
prefer physical games ones you can touch
maybe for our christmas present be aware
that these don't release until december
the 7th on subscription services ps now
subs can play the original gta 3 from
december the 7th and those on game pass
have a way better deal you can play san
andreas on release day this thursday the
grand theft auto trilogy is a remaster
and not a remake and by looking at the
early footage it's very easy to see why
all three games keep their og look but
they have been forced into modern times
with a few little tricks the character
models have been updated to look
acceptable but what the real advancement
here is the lighting headlights on
vehicles pop neons glow on the side of
buildings and explosions rip through the
air under the hood the updates are far
more important and impressive back in
2004 can you guess which button on a
controller we use to fire a weapon
circle that's right on a ps2 controller
we used circle and it was b on xbox
which is why we all played claw back
then and messed up our hands together of
course the modern way is to use the
shoulder triggers and the bumpers and
thankfully this has been rectified in
the trilogy as all games use the control
scheme perfected in gta 5. this includes
the revolutionary weapon wheel so if
you're playing gta online you can still
play vice city without needing to switch
button layouts
there's a few smaller updates too which
include the ability to place waypoints
on the map wow the early 2000s were
tough on us gamers we had to learn the
streets and navigate without gps
probably the greatest update to the
entire trilogy is that of immediately
restarting a mission if and when you
fail this may seem a simple update but
back then if we failed we had to get our
sorry butts all the way back across the
map to activate the mission again sit
through the cutscene again and then go
all the way back to where we just failed
the mission again it was hell but at
least it spawned a meme all we had to do
was follow the damn train cj we had to
do was follow the damn train cj all we
had to do was follow the damn train cj
follow the damn train cj another
important update is to draw distance gta
3 vice city and especially san andreas
had issues loading in scenery fast
enough at times it was like silent hill
waiting for buildings to load in 30 feet
away from us the definitive edition has
solved this issue and the draw distances
have been modernized and now should
operate much more like gta online with
low res textures seamlessly
transitioning to upscale resolution
textures as we get closer and if you're
on ps5 or xbox series x you can have all
this at 4k 60 frames a second
so now the real question which are you
going to play first here's a bunch of
things i found out about gta 3 vice city
and san andreas if you're a fan of
setting and story here's a super quick
breakdown of each game gta 3 is set in a
fictional new york city named liberty
city we play as claude a mute
protagonist who is arrested after being
set up by his girlfriend claude breaks
out of the prison transport with other
cons and eventually becomes a mafia
enforcer and wheel man in the seedy
underworld of liberty city always hoping
that he will once again see the woman
who tricked him gta vice city takes us
back in time to the mid-1980s the
liberty city mafia families are
expanding tommy vercetti is freshly
released from prison and sent to miami
aka vice city to establish a drug
operation there things go as wrong as
they can and tommy is left for dead it's
our job to build him back up to become
the scarface of vice city the undisputed
kingpin
vice city was actually the first gta
game with a fully voiced main character
and it was played by ray liotta
channeling his character from the
goodfellas movie gta san andreas takes
place in the 1990s in california los
santos is los angeles san fierro is san
francisco and les venturas is las vegas
in nevada we play as cj who returns home
after his mother is killed in a drive-by
shooting in the ganglands cj barely gets
time to grieve before he's immediately
forced to do the bidding of the local
police department he is framed for a
recent murder and should he not do what
they say they will send him to prison
and by the way the dirty cop is played
by samuel l jackson circle while doing
the bidding for officer 10 penny cj also
helps his childhood friends grow their
territory and commit quite a lot of
crimes out of the three games gta 3 is
the shortest taking about 15 hours to
complete the story missions there are 51
in total but for a completionist run
you'll need about 40 hours to finish the
full 77 missions and side missions next
is vice city which will take the average
gamer 20 hours to finish the 38 story
missions the thing is there is another
49 missible missions for the
completionist in you which will take
about 40 hours for a full playthrough of
all content and now the big boy san
andreas has 101 story missions to finish
the game making the average play through
about 30 hours the thing is san andreas
has countless side missions which are
replayable making the estimate to do
everything in san andreas a whopping 80
hours of your time grand theft auto san
andreas was so revolutionary at the time
we could become a firefighter and go on
calls to extinguish fires we could
become a courier and deliver parcels all
day there is even the ability to take a
crew on a burglary mission at night to
rob the rich folk san andreas included a
gang war mechanic which let the grove
street families take over areas of the
map using brute force they could also
lose that territory if they weren't
protecting it well enough i'll warn you
now watching the map turn green is
addictive but without a doubt the
greatest ever update to a gta game comes
in san andreas and it's all about food
cj puts in his body it's possible to
make carl obese i mean wow really a
beast it actually stunts his performance
he's he can run far less he can barely
leap fences and worst of all some
characters will flat out refuse to work
with him until he loses weight cj can
put this right by eating correctly and
visiting the gym
thick cj could become hench cj which
also feeds into a sex appeal mechanic in
the game cj can
caught ladies shall we say and each of
them likes a certain physique most of
them like thin or muscles but some of
the dirty gals like a big fat cj more
cushion for the pushing
i should stop talking now the fat thin
mechanic and the sex appeal and
mechanics weren't implemented in gta 4
and 5 making san andreas one of the most
unique gta games in history and to end
all this here are the maps for each of
the games and let's compare them to
other gta games the land mass in gta 3
is 4.38 kilometers squared which
compared to gta 5 is tiny gta 5 has a
massive land mass of 48 squared
kilometers vice city is 5.62 kilometers
squared and then take a look at san
andreas a massive 31.5 squared
kilometers of landmass this is so huge
it's actually bigger than gta 4 by a
long way so now i leave it to you which
game are you playing first with over 160
hours of gameplay across the three games
it doesn't matter that gta 6 probably
won't be here for another five years we
have lots to do in the meantime
i'm adam thank you for sticking around
till the end much appreciated which game
are you playing first i'm thinking vice
city what about you it's been a pleasure
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]